i want to ask you quickly on the border
and then i've got to get to california
but
fox news has learned from a senior
source
with customs and border protection rick
that there is a
plan under consideration right now for
border patrol agents in the rio grande
valley
area to begin releasing illegal border
crossers who claim asylum without
uh without issuing a notice to appear
meaning that they will depart custody
and they will not have a court date to
come back i mean this is just
extraordinary they come to the border
we're just going to release them
no court date and then they're just
getting to the interior of our country
look somehow the democrats have been
able to convince the media
and some in the public that their policy
is humane that they're being nicer
or that they're being more generous to
people
by letting people break the line and i i
have to
push back on this very hard americans
are very generous
we we allow a million people one million
people a year
to become american citizens in this
country but the fact is maria there are
tens of millions more who would like to
become
citizens you have to have a line you
have to be able to say to people
wait in line wait your turn and we will
make a decision
what the democrats are doing right now
is breaking the line
first and second generation americans
supported donald trump and the
republicans in this last election
like never before these are people who
waited
in line you want to be humane you should
tell the people who waited in line
that you are not going to allow line
jumpers or people to rush the border
republicans have to do a better job on
making sure that we take the mantle to
say
we want immigrants in this country we
just want an orderly process
because we have so many people i can
tell you as
managing embassy berlin and embassy
germany
we have a plethora of people
who are waiting to come into this
country and if you just all of a sudden
say
rush the border we're going to have a
huge
bigger crisis than we have right now